vegan barbecue so today we are gonna be
trying vegan barbecue
I am from a barbecue town she is from
opposing barber like this is something
that they pretend that they do I'm from
Memphis Tennessee and we obviously have
the betta barbecue how do you have your
meat Oh like medium well medium rare is
the way to go I'm excited I'm interested
to see what this tastes like I've
learned it looks like sloppy joe to me
it does it smells like barbecue is
low-key excited about this this is good
rice is a trick no this is good yes good
[Music]
eating
oh my god bring on the next one
cheers Cheers
when you eat this you know there isn't
meat in it it tastes like a hot dog but
the textures mm-hmm this is not for me
this is not of God God wanted us to have
hot dogs either because that has no real
taste right
but if Beyonce wasn't one of her vegan
phases the Beyonce I was like do you
want a hot tub solutely yes several RV
please in the gospel my ribs like why
you got to try for like the number one
dish nope it tastes like corn bread that
is like not sweet not today stay in
protrude you don't taste anything I'm
honestly not that mad at it someone
who's trying to cut back on me I would
definitely look into some of these
options I felt like this is not gonna
make me go vegan in any way but I will
eat that vegan pulled pork again like I
would totally go VIN that I'd stay away
from the hot dog yeah vegan food is good
you can find some really good vegan
stuff and then you can find some really
nasty stuff it's just like me it is just
like me you know
mine's a good meat bad meat you know who
you are
[Music]